das grundgesetz ist es dass aus unserem
staat einen demokratischen rechtsstaat
macht gemacht hat mit der bindung von
verwaltung und rechtsprechung an gesetz
und recht mit der bindung der
gesetzgebung also von uns an die
verfassungsmäßige ordnung wurden die
grundanliegen dieses rechtsstaates in
den letzten 70 jahren verwirklicht was
die verfassungsgebung wollten das ist
uns die afd
als inzwischen leider einziger partei
der rechtsstaatlichkeit ein anliegen
also vor allem grundrechte
gewaltenteilung und unabhängige gerichte
doch immer mehr massiv zunehmend seit
einigen jahren meine damen und herren
wird das recht wird der rechtsstaat von
ihnen von den altparteien und alt
fraktionen ignoriert geboren und mit den
füßen getreten
der rechtsstaat mal in der modernen
erodiert und das auf nahezu sämtlichen
ebenen fangen wir ganz oben an beim
staatsoberhaupt den bundespräsidenten
der auf der tribüne ist und daher
steinmeier sie machten offen werbung für
linksextremistische veranstaltungen die
der wie der verfassungsschutz von
sachsen vor kurzem herausgefunden hat
die veranstaltungen auf den musikgruppen
sogenannte musikgruppen ihre primitiven
gewaltfantasien ausgelebt hatten nicht
meine die peinliche veranstaltung in
chemnitz sie haben gratulationsschreiben
an menschenverachtende mörderische
regime gesandt ich meine den iran
man arbeite an die bundeskanzlerin
die bundesregierung nicht wahrhaben herr
kollege brandmal der präsident der
bundespräsident ist unser aller starts
überhaupt wenn er die ehre unserer
männer die uns die ihre anregung zur
debatte teilzunehmen ist es nicht für
sie die gelegenheit ihn zu kritisieren
bitte unterlassen sie das weil auch sie
an die bundeskanzlerin
die bundesregierung sämtliche
altparteien verantwortlich für
millionenfachen rechtsbruch im rahmen
der von ihnen verursachten
masseneinwanderung damit auch
mitverantwortlich für die heraus zu
reduzierenden morde tötungsdelikte
vergewaltigungen und viele andere
verbrechen und vergehen massenhafte
verstöße gegen artikel 16a grundgesetzt
verantwortlich für die
gesellschaftlichen verwerfungen und
kosten in vieler milliarden-höhe meine
damen und herren an denen noch
generationen von deutschen leiden werden
und über die das parlament nie
entschieden hat verantwortlich sind sie
alle für politische verfolgungen alles
bürgerlichen alles vernünftigen alles
deutschen im besten sinne und für die
politische instrumentalisierung des
inlandsgeheimdienstes gegen die größte
oppositionsfraktion sie sind
verantwortlich für arbeitsplatzverluste
und berufsverbote für tätliche angriffe
auf personen und sachen und das alles
unter dem mantel des kampfes gegen recht
dieser kampf gegen rechts meine damen
und herren kommen als fraktion ist
pervertiert gegen einen kampf gegen das
recht das auf ihrem mist gewachsen
alles verstöße gegen artikel 2 und 3 des
grundgesetzes neben sie hinzu die zensur
gesetze des jammers verstoß gegen
artikel 5 nehmen sie die beliebig machen
der ehe verstoß gegen artikel 6
grundgesetz meine damen und herren die
liste dessen was die gründung der
republik was die väter ist waren
übrigens 61 und mütter ist waren 4 des
grundgesetzes sich nie und nimmer in
ihren schlimmsten träumen hätten erahnen
lassen wie sie sich beliebig verlängern
und das alles ist möglich obwohl es das
grundgesetz gibt obwohl es unser
grundgesetz gibt das ist alles möglich
weil sie das grundgesetzt seit ihren
sonntagsreden loben aber nicht wirklich
leben meine damen und herren von den
altparteien lassen sie uns gemeinsam
das grundgesetz leben mit den
demokratischen geist wieder erfüllen und
ja an einigen stellen auch verbessern
wir haben ein paar wunschzettel von
ihnen ja heute schon gehört wir sind da
weiter gegangen
wir haben sogar einen antrag gemacht wir
waren parlamentarisch tätig wir werden
die nachher tone debatte unter artikel 1
und unterhalb besonders gut 31 f in die
ausschüsse überweisen ich denke da
einige punkte die uns am herzen liegen
direktwahl des bundespräsidenten wir
wollen direktdemokratische elemente
volksabstimmungen stärken
wir wollen die amtszeit begrenzung der
bundeskanzlerin einführen und wir wollen
die gewaltenteilung wiederherstellen und
daher meine damen und herren fordern wir
sie von der afg auf tm sind alle vor den
altparteien zurück auf den boden unseres
grundgesetzes leben sie den geist des
grundgesetzes wieder so wie ihn sich die
väter und mütter des grundgesetzes
vorgestellt haben und nicht so wie sie
in pervertieren in der erosion unseres
rechtsstaats und vor allem einen namen
dass ich das zum abschluss sagen
denken sie bitte daran dass ihre
redezeit genau richtig halte bereits der
präsident eigentlich ist es eine
beerdigungs veranstaltung jede einzelne
richtlinie jeder einzelne verordnung der
europäischen union steht inzwischen im
rang über unserem grundgesetz und das
haben sie zu verantworten dafür keinen
danken
[Applaus]